how important is it for filmmakers to
keep up with the latest trends in camera
technology I mean has it been a habit of
yours to check out DSLR weekly you know
I mean I think it's important I think
it's important to be aware with what new
tools and toys are out there just
because it there may be a thing that you
want to do that's in your head that
you're not able to execute it's funny
because I was just at the Kubrick
exhibit but you should totally go this
great exhibit at LACMA Kubrick and I was
read there one of them does everything
is there you know all this documentation
all these letters and storyboards and
everything it's so cool one of the
things I noticed was there was a letter
from I can't remember who is producing
at the time letter to Kubrick from a
producer friend saying I just saw this
amazing thing it's this device that
enables the camera to be free floating
on an operator and you can follow people
downstairs and up the uphills and the
camera remains stable and I think this
will be an incredible you should check
this thing out and it weighs something
he was talking about basically he was
talking about a Steadicam before it was
the Steadicam
and it was like and the letter was
Stanley you need to see this because I
think you're gonna these are their shots
that you have in your head that you up
to now you couldn't it couldn't achieve
but now with this thing you can you know
so in a way I think it's it's really
important because it helps you realize
the things that that are in your mind
better the problem is is that sometimes
that technology is not portable like
there are millions of shots that I would
do that that I would like to do that I
would do with a techno crane which is a
great piece of equipment which is
essentially a telescoping arm so like if
you wanted to do a dolly move they were
like you know I'm trying to think it
moves where then really use it well like
in The Thin Red Thin Red Line there's a
lot of shots where they're like
assaulting this kind of this Hill like
foliage blowing and they're following
the troops up the hill and it's this
rock steady sort of tracking shot where
you're tracking you know with these
soldiers as they crawl this help and you
realize well it can't be a dolly move
because how do you delay dolly track up
Mountain and it's not really a Steadicam
shot it's and what it is it's a
telescoping arm so that means the camera
is on an arm that literally telescopes
out like this it gets longer and longer
and you can follow people that way
it's even do incredible shot can go
through windows that nobody's gonna be
outside a house and you can be pushing
it on the house and go literally like
right through the window into the living
room that's a super expensive piece of
equipment I can never afford it yeah
down to low-budget movies that I've made
how about like this we great for the
techno crane but I can't afford it so
then I have to reconsider work with an
edit or something like that which can
also be fun creatively but for me the
the magazine that I read all the time
and I still read is American
cinematographer American cinematographer
which again it is what it is it sounds
like it's a journal of scimitar ephie
but it just features whatever is coming
out but from the perspective of the DP
and that's really good for directors
because I think all strong directors
essentially need to be as bright and as
informed as their own DP in order to
visualize it in order to direct the
cinematographer and that move that
magazine every month is loaded with just
like this is the lens we use this is the
this is the piece of grip equipment we
use in lights we use they include charts
so for a film student or film maker it's
a great really in-depth technical
behind-the-scenes journal and you can
get it anywhere or get a subscription
you can get it online it's a great grade
I still refer to that all the time it's
like a so it's a film geeks techno geeks
look at at how movies are made it's
almost like the yeah it's like the
techno geek version of Entertainment
Weekly you know instead of like oh well
this is what she was wearing those who
she was dating it's like this is we were
using this particular wide-angle lens
and it was on this you know shop maker
car that we blah blah blah blah so it's
all very technical and what's cool it's
very cool
you